Sure enough, the reason they're called unholy donuts is because they don't have holes in them, which I didn't put together. That's pretty clever. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 116, recorded on February 1st, 2023. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Bryce, we follow up part two of our two-part conversation that started in episode 115, and we solve a follow-up problem to max gap called max gap count in C++23. Same problem. We'll assume that we already have a sorted list of numbers.
果然，它们之所以被称为“不神圣的甜甜圈”，是因为里面没有洞，我之前没把这两者联系起来。这挺聪明的。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 116 期，录制于 2023 年 2 月 1 日。我是康纳，今天我的联合主持人布莱斯也在，我们继续探讨在第 115 期开始的、分为两部分的对话的第二部分，并在 C++23 中解决最大间隙（max gap）的一个后续问题，即最大间隙计数（max gap count）。同样的问题。我们假设我们已经有了一个排好序的数字列表。
And the question is now not what is the maximum of adjacent values, difference between adjacent values, but what is the count of the maximum difference between adjacent values? And this, this is where things get interesting. So wait, so wait, you want the, you want to know how many times that maximum gap occurs. Yes. And I realized probably I should have done this 20 minutes ago. Also, we might be bleeding in. This might be part two now of this episode.
而现在的问题不再是相邻值的最大值是多少，相邻值之间的差值是多少，而是相邻值之间的最大差值出现了多少次？这就是有趣的地方。等等，所以你想知道，你想知道那个最大间隙出现了多少次。是的。我意识到我可能应该在 20 分钟前就这么做。另外，我们可能会串台。这可能是本期节目的第二部分了。
I probably should have given an example. So for instance, for the first problem, if we had the numbers 1, 3, 5, and 10, the differences are 2, 2, and 5. So the answer to that question is 5. But for the second problem, the answer would be 1 because there is 1, 5. However, if the sequence was 1, 3, 5, 10, 15, 20, our differences are then 2, 2, 5, 5, 5. And so then you want the count of the number of fives, whatever the maximum difference is. In this case, it would be three.
我大概应该举个例子。例如，对于第一个问题，如果我们有数字 1、3、5 和 10，差值分别是 2、2 和 5。所以该问题的答案是 5。但对于第二个问题，答案将是 1，因为只有一个 5。然而，如果序列是 1、3、5、10、15、20，我们的差值就是 2、2、5、5、5。那么你想要的是数字 5 的计数，无论最大差值是什么。在本例中，答案将是 3。
And it's only a slightly different problem, but the implications on how you solve this I think are interesting. I'm not so convinced convinced it's just another reduction it is you just you just you just how many more reductions it's one right is it okay so you you do your max reduction but this time but instead of just reducing a single piece of information, which is what's the maximum value, you reduce your reduction operator returns to pieces of information,
这只是一个略有不同的问题，但对如何解决这个问题的启发，我认为很有趣。我不太确信这只是又一次规约（reduction），它就是，你只需，你只需，你只需——有多少次规约？是一次，对吧？好吧，所以你做最大值规约，但这一次，规约算子返回的不是单个信息（即最大值是什么），而是返回两个信息，
one of which is the maximum value, and then the next of which is how many times you've seen it. And then any time you see a new maximum value, and then the next of which is how many times you've seen it. And then any time you see a new maximum value, you reset the how many times have I seen it to zero. So that doesn't work. I'll ask why. Why doesn't it work? Are you asking me now?
其中一个是最大值，另一个是你见过它多少次。然后，每当你看到一个新的最大值时，然后另一个是你见过它多少次。然后，每当你看到一个新的最大值时，你将“我见过它多少次”重置为零。所以这行不通。我会问为什么。为什么行不通？你现在是在问我吗？
Yeah, I'm asking you now. So what if our example is one, one, what if it's a zero? Actually, how do I do this? What if it's one, three? All right, it's too hard for me to come up with an example on the fly. But basically, what if in resetting your maximum...
对，我正问你呢。那么，如果我们的例子是 1、1，如果是 0 呢？实际上，我该怎么做？如果是 1、3 呢？好吧，让我现场举个例子太难了。但基本上，如果在重置你的最大值时……
Actually, you're right. Of course. Wow. It's all reductions. All the way down. It's all reductions. Wow. See, your problem is
其实，你是对的。当然。哇。全都是规约。到底都是规约。全都是规约。哇。你看，你的问题是
you don't always go for the one pass answer you should always go for the one pass answer well so no the the the example that i was trying to construct was what if you when you reset your maximum you've already passed by that maximum and you lost count but that's flawed thinking in that anytime you, by definition, anytime you meet a new maximum, you haven't seen it yet. Yeah. Isn't math great? Isn't math great? There's probably, you know, I probably have the book here. Yeah, I do. Introduction to Optimization. This is probably some, you know, all of these reduction, all of these like find style reductions
你并不总是追求单次遍历（one pass）的答案，你总是应该追求单次遍历的答案。好吧，不，我试图构建的例子是：如果你在重置最大值时，你已经错过了那个最大值并且失去了计数？但这种想法是有缺陷的，因为根据定义，每当你遇到一个新的最大值时，你以前不可能见过它。是的。数学不是很棒吗？数学不是很棒吗？可能，你知道，我可能把书放在这儿。对，我有。优化导论。这可能是一些，你知道，所有这些规约，所有这些类似查找风格的规约，
or like reductions where you're searching for some answer, they're probably all some class of optimization problem. And it would probably be interesting for us to research and to think about that more at some point. I'm amused here that like two minutes ago when Connor was saying things, I was sitting here like trying to work out the problem in my head and like saying wow and things in the background. And now Connor's doing the same thing. My mind is literally exploding. Well, I use literally in the non-literal sense. And I apologize to those that are upset by that.
或者像那种搜索某种答案的规约，它们可能都属于某类最优化问题。而且，在某个时候，我们去研究并深入思考这个问题可能会很有趣。我在这里觉得挺好玩的，就像两分钟前康纳在说话时，我坐在那儿试图在脑子里琢磨这个问题，在背景里说“哇”之类的话。现在康纳也在做同样的事。我的脑子简直要炸了。好吧，我用“简直（literally）”并不是在字面意义上用的。我向那些对此感到不满的人道歉。
My mind is exploding because two of the problems in my top 10 problems that are going to lead towards this algorithm course are maximum consecutive ones and longest consecutive increasing sequence. I refer to those as MCO and LCIS. And both of those, I don't want to do this because, oh yeah, I was going to bring this up. There's a new APL podcast called The APL Show. Are you running The APL Show? No, no, no. It's made by two of my co-hosts on my other podcasts.
我的脑子要炸了，因为排进我前 10 个、将引导至这门算法课程的问题中，有两个是“最大连续 1”和“最长连续递增子序列”。我将它们称为 MCO 和 LCIS。这两个问题，我不想这么做，因为，哦对了，我要提起这个。有一个新的 APL 播客叫 The APL Show。你在运营 The APL Show 吗？不，不，不。它是我其他播客的两个联合主持人制作的。
But they share screens constantly and one of them has a chalkboard behind them. And I tried listening to the first couple and I know Adam listens to this podcast who's one of the co-hosts of The New APL Show. And so I haven't told him, given this feedback. But like it's almost impossible to follow like they read papers together and they talk about things that they don't actually spell out for the listener at times we do that all the time too
但他们经常共享屏幕，其中一个人的背后有一块黑板。我试着听了前几期，我知道亚当会听这个播客，他是新 APL 播客的联合主持人之一。所以我还没告诉他，没给他这个反馈。但就像，几乎没法跟随他们的节奏，比如他们一起阅读论文，讨论一些有时并没有向听众真正解释清楚的事情——我们不也经常那样吗？
no I mean but we've done I think probably not we think we've done a good job but probably we fell into the no no I didn't say I didn't say we did a good job I said we do that all the time with the implication being that's not a good job, but probably we fell into the mistake. No, no, no. I didn't say we did a good job. I said we do that all the time with the implication being that's not a good thing. No, that's not what I'm saying is I was about to say that we do do a good job, but probably like in my head, I think we do a good job whenever we screen share. But the thing that I've learned from listening to their podcast is that one, don't have a chalkboard. Never have a chalkboard and start writing on that chalkboard because unless if you're
不，我的意思是，我们做过——我觉得可能没有吧，我们觉得自己做得很好，但可能我们陷入了……不，不，我没说我们做得很好，我是说我们经常那样做，其潜台词是那做得并不好，但可能我们陷入了这种错误中。不，不，不。我没说我们做得很好。我说我们经常那样做，其潜台词是那不是一件好事。不，我不是那个意思，我是正要说我们确实做得很好，但可能在我的脑海里，每当共享屏幕时，我都觉得我们做得很好。不过我从听他们的播客中学到的一点是，第一，不要有黑板。绝对不要有黑板并在黑板上写字，因为除非你在
spelling out what they're drawing or writing, you have no idea. Like so much time, you'll just hear Rich going, and you see that's beautiful. And I'm like, I have no idea what you're seeing. And the other thing is that I think probably when we've been coding, we also fall into the same trap where we think we're spelling it out well enough, but there are times where we're leaving off 50%. Well, I think that our opinion of this podcast and our listeners' opinion of how this podcast is going is very different. But I'm telling you, this should have been a YouTube channel. And we're so photogenic.
详细解释他们画或写的东西，否则你根本不知道。比如有很长一段时间，你只会听到里奇发出“嗯”的声音，然后你说“看，那多美妙”。而我在想：“我根本不知道你在看什么。”另一件事是，我想可能当我们在写代码时，我们也陷入了同样的陷阱，我们以为自己已经解释得够清楚了，但有时我们漏掉了 50% 的内容。好吧，我觉得我们对这个播客的看法以及听众对这个播客进展的看法非常不同。但我告诉你，这本该是个 YouTube 频道。而且我们这么上镜。
People could get to meet my adorable dog, although my adorable dog's not here right now. But yeah, it should have been a YouTube channel. Everybody could get to see my great New York apartment. Oh, and you know what? Connor, look at my screen because the blinds are down right now. And watch this. Are you watching? Yeah.
大家还可以见到我可爱的狗狗，虽然我可爱的狗狗现在不在这里。但是，是的，这本该是个 YouTube 频道。所有人都能看到我漂亮的纽约公寓。哦，你知道吗？康纳，看我的屏幕，因为百叶窗现在拉下来了。看这个。你在看吗？对。
Yeah, I've seen this before. Is this it? I thought there was going to be like balloons or something. No, I didn't set up ones, but you can see the Chrysler Building. I'd have to actually adjust the camera up a little bit for you to see the Chrysler Building. There we go. There's the Chrysler Building. But now you can't see me me and seeing me is more important
对，我以前看过这个。就是这样吗？我以为会有气球之类的东西。不，我没准备那些，不过你能看到克莱斯勒大厦。我其实得把摄像头稍微往上调一点，你才能看到克莱斯勒大厦。好了。克莱斯勒大厦就在那儿。但现在你看不到我了，而看我比
than seeing the christ they're building so all right back back okay my my mind is exploded you you came to some realization and it seemed like it was a realization about the all these i i had to open up my github repo but we won't we should make that a rule we no longer share screens if we're going to talk about code i have to communicate it clearly enough to you over the microphone. But it actually, so LCIS was not the problem I wanted to mention. So it's maximum consecutive ones and then Cadain's algorithm, which is also known as maximum subarray sum. And we're not going to get into the details of that. But basically, those are solvable with a one or two character.
看克莱斯勒大厦更重要，所以，好吧，回到正题。好吧，我的脑子炸了。你得出了一些认识，看起来像是关于所有这些——我不得不打开我的 GitHub 仓库，但我们不会这么做——我们应该定一个规矩，如果我们讨论代码，我们就再也不共享屏幕了。我必须通过麦克风向你表达得足够清楚。但实际上，LCIS 并不是我想提到的那个问题。所以它是最大连续 1，然后是卡丹算法（Kadane's algorithm），也就是最大子数组和（maximum subarray sum）。我们不会深入探讨细节。但基本上，那些可以用一两个字符解决。
Let's actually look at the difference. It's with a. Anyways, we're not going to do this live. It's like a one or two character difference. It's basically a scan followed by a reduction. Yeah. And. I'm trying to think now, is this the exact same thing?
我们来看看区别。它带有。总之，我们不会现场做这个。这就像是一两个字符的区别。它基本上是一个扫描（scan）加上一个规约。对。还有。我现在在想，这难道是完全一样的东西吗？
Which if it is, is going to absolutely like, it's going to make my brain explode. Because this will now be, because yeah, it's, so in this case, if you're if the state you're carrying is the number, the count of the maximum difference. Yeah. And then every once in a while, you just might need to reset that. Although. I don't that's actually just a reduction, right? It's just a reduction. It's just a reduction right it's just a reduction it's just a reduction yeah and then it's a reduction that carries two pieces of state yeah no yes it's a reduction that carries
如果是的话，那绝对会——那会让我的大脑爆炸。因为现在这将是，因为，是的，所以在这种情况下，如果你携带的状态是数字、最大差值的计数。对。然后偶尔，你可能只需要重置它。虽然。我不——那其实只是个规约，对吧？它只是个规约。它只是个规约，对吧？它只是个规约。它只是个规约。对，然后它是一个携带了
two pieces of state and then you just toss the first one and keep the count the first piece being what the max is wow well this blows everything up um because the interesting part of that problem what i initially thought was that in an array language you could use like an s combinator to basically find the maximum then do a rank polymorphic equals with the original array. So in our case, when we had, you know, one, three, five, 10, 15, 20, you do your adjacent difference on that gives you two, two, five, five, five, you then calculate the max. So that's going to be your first operation in your S combinator. And then the binary operation. So now you've got your original list and your maximum, and then you put an equal sign between
两个状态的规约。对，不，是的，它是一个携带了两个状态的规约，然后你只要丢弃第一个状态并保留计数，第一个状态是最大值是多少。哇，这把一切都颠覆了。嗯，因为那个问题有趣的部分，我最初认为，在数组语言中，你可以使用类似 S 组合子（S combinator）的东西来基本上找到最大值，然后用原始数组做一个秩多态的等号（rank polymorphic equals）。所以对我们来说，当我们有（你知道的）1、3、5、10、15、20 时，你对它做相邻差值运算，得到 2、2、5、5、5，然后你计算最大值。所以这将是你的 S 组合子中的第一个操作。然后是二元操作。所以现在你有了你的原始列表和最大值，然后你在
that and that'll turn it into 00111. And then you do a plus reduction. And it's interesting because in J you do that with a hook, which is the S combinator. In BQN, you do that with the S or the Sigma combinator, which are the names of those are after and before. But in APL, you don't with the S or the Sigma combinator, which are the names of those are after and before. But in APL, you don't have the S combinator. So you have to use the Phi combinator, aka a fork, where you fix one of the operations to be identity. So you get back your original list. Anyways, it's very interesting. But now you've completely broken my whole Eureka moment or not
那个和那个之间画一个等号，这会把它变成 00111。然后你做一个加法规约。有趣的是，在 J 语言中，你用一个钩子（hook）来做到这一点，这就是 S 组合子。在 BQN 中，你用 S 或 Sigma 组合子来做到这一点，这两个名字分别代表“之后”和“之前”。但在 APL 中，你没有 S 组合子。所以你必须使用 Phi 组合子，也就是分叉（fork），你把其中一个操作固定为恒等操作。这样你就拿回了你的原始列表。总之，这非常有趣。但现在你彻底打破了我的顿悟时刻，或者说，不是
Eureka moment, but just all the time i've spent thinking about this well and there's there's another there's a there's sort of a next step algorithm that i i think of um which is um you you've your first version of this was find the largest gap your second one was count how many gaps there are um the next you know thing that you might want to do that could be useful is give me the locations of all those gaps. And that one you could solve with a similar thing where your two pieces of state are what's the maximum and then a list or a vector. Um, or when I say list, I, I don't, is this a different problem you're solving?
顿悟时刻，而是我花在思考这个上的所有时间。嗯，还有另一个——有一种算是下一步的算法，我想到的，嗯，就是——你的这个版本的第一个版本是找到最大的间隙，第二个版本是计算有多少个间隙，接下来（你知道的）你可能想做的事情、可能会有用的是：给我所有这些间隙的位置。那个问题你可以用类似的方法解决，你的两个状态是最大值是什么，然后是一个列表或向量。嗯，或者当我说是列表时，我——这不是你要解决的另一个问题吧？
That's a different problem. Okay. It's, it's like, I want to know, I want to find the locations, um, uh, of, of, of all these gaps. Um, and so my state is, you know, a, um, the list instead of just account. Yeah. Yeah. is a list instead of just a count. Yeah, yeah. And the only downside with that
那是另一个问题。好吧。这就像是，我想知道，我想找到所有这些间隙的位置。所以我的状态是一个列表，而不仅仅是一个计数。对，对。是一个列表，而不仅仅是一个计数。对，对。唯一美中不足的是
is that needing to have a vector of the locations means that you need to have some dynamic storage for it. But I think in most cases, it's going to be a small list. But I actually imagine that there is some useful problems that you could solve with that like if you were if you were looking if you if you wanted to like slice up a sequence in some way like like you know we've been using gaps in this like the maximum difference between
需要有一个位置向量，这意味着你需要为此有一些动态存储。但我认为在大多数情况下，它会是一个很小的列表。不过我实际上想象，有一些你可以用它解决的有用问题，比如如果你在寻找——如果你想以某种方式切分序列——比如（你知道的）我们在这里将间隙用作两个整数之间的最大差值，但搜索标准实际上可以是任何东西，对吧？它可以是（你知道的），
two integers here but the search criterion could actually be anything right it could be you know, we've been using gaps in this, like the maximum difference between two integers here, but the search criterion could actually be anything, right? It could be, you know, any, you know, it could be finding the end of a sentence. It could be count how many sentences there are, you know, something like that. Or count how many words there are. You know, things like that um uh or count how many words there are um uh you know things like that actually that's an interesting thing that you could like i i've shown um uh in some of my talks i'd love to use word count like a parallel word count as an example um you could you could do um like something similar to that where you find like you, you know, what's the, um, uh, what's the longest word in this text? And then like, also like how many times does the longest word in this text occur? Um just saying, I think that the interesting case is the one where I say like, hey, find all of the places in this sequence that satisfy this criterion and then give me their locations. So like, hey, like here's a string, find all the ends of the sentences so that I can cut this string up into a vector of sentences. And I think with this type of reduction, you can in a single pass, a single parallelizable pass, you can do, you could do an adjacent transform where you get the diffs, then another transform that does a make pair or make tuple where it initializes the second value in that
我们在这里将间隙用作两个整数之间的最大差值，但搜索标准实际上可以是任何东西，对吧？它可以是（你知道的），任何东西（你知道的），它可以是找到句子的结尾。它可以是计算有多少个句子（你知道的），诸如此类。或者计算有多少个单词。诸如此类的事情，嗯，呃，或者计算有多少个单词，嗯，呃，诸如此类的事情。其实，这是一个有趣的事情，就像我——我在我的一些演讲中展示过，我喜欢用词频统计——比如并行词频统计作为一个例子——你可以做类似的事情，你找到类似——你（你知道的）：“这个文本中最长的单词是什么？”然后像：“这个文本中最长单词出现了多少次？”我只是随口说说，我认为有趣的情况是我说：“嘿，在这个序列中找到所有满足这个标准的点，然后把它们的位置给我。”所以，比如：“嘿，这里有一个字符串，找到所有句子的结尾，这样我就可以把这个字符串切成一个句子向量。”而且我认为使用这种类型的规约，你可以在单次遍历中，单次可并行的遍历中，你可以做一个相邻变换来得到差值，然后另一个变换用于创建一个配对（make pair）或创建元组（make tuple），它将初始化那个
tuple, which is going to be the count to one. And now you have a monoid. You can do a fully parallelized because you're basically like initially when i was thinking like how parallelizable is it it's like well it's not really 100 parallelizable because you still need to do a left fold to make sure that like every single time you hit a max it resets but actually that's not true at all yeah that property holds even if you you break your sequence or array up into a bunch of chunks whatever result is yielded is the count of the max diff in that chunk. And when you merge those chunks together, like it's, it's monoidal. Um, it'll, you'll always end up with the right answer, regardless if you're doing a left fold,
元组中的第二个值，也就是计数为 1。现在你拥有了一个幺半群（monoid）。你可以进行完全并行化，因为你基本上——起初当我在想“它有多大程度的可并行性”时，我觉得“它其实不是 100% 可并行的，因为你仍然需要做一个左折叠（left fold）来确保每次碰到最大值时它都会重置”。但实际上，这完全不是真的。是的，这个属性甚至在你把序列或数组拆成一堆块时也成立，无论产生什么结果，都是该块中最大差值的计数。当你把这些块合并在一起时，它是幺半群性质的。无论你做的是左折叠、
a right fold, or some arbitrarily, you know, tree reduction. So, so I, which is, which is so awesome. I hate to admit that I might have learned things in college, because college was not a pleasant experience for me, something that we discussed on this podcast before. I don't have any problem with college. I know that a lot of people learned things in college and had a good time there. I did not. I was very happy to get out there. So I hate to admit that I learned anything in college. However, once again, going back to optimization theory, I am recalling learning properties about local minimum and maximum and the relation to global minimum and maximum. And I think some of those things apply to this class of reductions too. And I think that I'm going to give you a homework, which is that I think your homework is that you need to go and do some reading on optimization theory.
右折叠，还是某种任意的（你知道的）树形规约，你最终总是会得到正确的答案。所以，这太棒了。我讨厌承认我可能在大学里学到了东西，因为大学对我的体验并不愉快，这是我们在本尼迪克特播客中讨论过的话题。我对上大学没有任何意见。我知道很多人在大学里学到了东西，并在那里度过了美好的时光。我没有。我很高兴能离开那里。所以我讨厌承认我在大学里学到了任何东西。然而，再次回到优化理论，我回想起学习关于局部极小值和极大值及其与全局极小值和极大值的关系的属性。我认为其中一些东西也适用于这类规约。我想我要给你布置一个家庭作业，我认为你的家庭作业是你需要去阅读一些关于优化理论的书籍。
I would mail you – What's going to be more optimal than a commutative associative monoid operation that you can put on a GPU. No, no, but what I mean, by optimization theory, I mean, mathematical optimization. I mean, like finding, you know, the minimum or maximum of some function. Okay, you really need to go and learn about this
我会寄给你——还有什么能比你可以放在 GPU 上的可交换结合的幺半群操作更优化的呢？不，不，但我的意思是，优化理论，我指的是数学优化。我指的是，寻找（你知道的）某些函数的最小值或最大值。好吧，你真的需要去了解这个，
because you know nothing about it. I would mail you my introduction to optimization book um uh what am i gonna get i got so many things to learn i gotta learn the jelly programming language have you heard of that is this is it gonna be more the last time i mailed you something if you recall it got seized by canadian customs it's true did you ever get it i did yeah but now i've got like 20 rapid tests sitting in my shelves because uh i don't understand it but some of the grocery stores started handing them out for free at some point when at another point they were like illegal to hand out it's yeah but things
因为你对它一无所知。我会把我的《优化导论》书寄给你，嗯，呃——我能得到什么？我有那么多东西要学，我得学 Jelly 编程语言。你听说过这个吗？这会更——上次我寄给你东西时，如果你还记得的话，它被加拿大海关扣了。真的吗？你后来拿到了吗？拿到了，是的。但现在我的架子上有大概 20 个快速检测盒，因为，嗯，我不明白，但有些杂货店在某个时候开始免费分发它们，而在另一个时候它们又是违法的。是的，但事情
changed it is an important clarification that when i when i'm talking about optimization here i don't mean like optimization the computer science i mean like optimization in the computer science i mean like optimization in the mathematical sense and like solving optimization problems all right i'm not sure what i will you haven't convinced me it pains me but what what am i it pains what am i going to get out of it it pains me that i learned something in college it really does am i gonna have to go read my introduction optimization book yeah but yeah how about say how about your homework assignment i'll go learn the jelly programming language. I got to be on a plane in like 36 hours. I don't have time for this stuff.
变了。这是一个重要的澄清：当我在这里谈论优化时，我指的不是计算机科学意义上的优化，我指的是，计算机科学意义上的优化——我指的是数学意义上的优化，以及解决最优化问题。好吧，我不确定我会——你还没说服我。这让我很痛苦，但是——这很痛苦——我能从中得到什么？我痛苦的是我在大学里学到了东西，真的。我是不是得去读我的《优化导论》书？对，但是，话说回来，你的家庭作业怎么样？我去学 Jelly 编程语言。我大概 36 小时后就要坐飞机了。我可没时间搞这些东西。
That sounds like a great learning opportunity. There's nothing that I love more than going to the airport. Tons of podcast opportunities, standing in line for customs. Everybody's angry. Me, I'm listening to Oxide and Friends. One, I don't stand in lines at airports and two i'm never angry at airports that's true i love airports airports cafeterias what do they call them food courts whoo it's one of my favorite places in the world um buddy buddy we we really have to fly together more we really have to fly together more why that's not going to change me loving uh airport food courts i'm gonna take you to some airport lounges, and then you're going to be unable to fly like a regular person.
听起来是一个极好的学习机会。没有什么比去机场更让我高兴的了。有大量的播客机会，在海关排长队。每个人都很生气。而我，我在听 Oxide and Friends。第一，我在机场不排队；第二，我在机场从不生气。这是真的，我喜欢机场。机场自助餐厅——他们叫什么来着？美食广场。哇。这是我在世界上最喜欢的地方之一，嗯。老兄，老兄，我们真的得一起多飞几次。我们真的得一起多飞几次。为什么？那不会改变我对机场美食广场的喜爱。我要带你去一些机场贵宾室，然后你就会变得像个普通人一样无法坐飞机了。
I've been in several lounges, and depending on the airport and the lounge— Connor, you've been in lounges, but you haven't been in price-quality lounges. This is probably true have i told you this story about the kathai pacific um uh dan dan mian noodles no the kathai pacific first class lounge in uh london heathrow terminal three um maybe the one saving grace of london heathrow as an airport. They have great food options. It's like one of my favorite lounges. And they have these Dan Dan Mian noodles on the menu. And they're really, really good.
我去过好几个贵宾室，根据机场和贵宾室的不同——康纳，你去过贵宾室，但你没去过高品质的贵宾室。这大概是真的。我给你讲过国泰航空嗯，呃，担担面的故事吗？没有。伦敦希思罗机场 3 号航站楼的国泰航空头等舱贵宾室，嗯，可能是伦敦希思罗作为机场唯一的救赎。他们有很棒的食物选择。它就像是我最喜欢的贵宾室之一。而且他们的菜单上有这种担担面。真的非常好吃。
It comes in, when I, I've tried to order Dan Dan Mian noodles in New York to get something similar, but it's different because the ones that they have the um, it's, it's different because the ones that they have the lounge, um, it's, they're like drenched in sauce. It's basically like a, it's like a, um, you know, almost like a, a soup with noodles in it. Um, and the sauce is this like really spicy peanut, um, uh, sauce and it's really, really good. And I get it every time I transit through London. Some people in my family have suggested that I maybe fly to London solely to go to this airport lounge. But anyways, I love them so much and I can't find a place that makes them the same way in New York.
端上来的时候——当我，我曾在纽约尝试点担担面来找点类似的东西，但它不一样，因为他们在贵宾室里的那些，嗯，它不一样，因为他们在贵宾室里的那些，嗯，它们就像是被酱汁浸透了。基本上就像是一个，嗯，几乎就像是一个，嗯，你知道的，带面条的汤。嗯，而且酱汁是一种非常辣的花生，嗯，呃，酱汁，真的非常非常好吃。每次我经伦敦转机我都会吃。我家的某些人甚至建议我可能应该专门飞到伦敦去这个机场贵宾室。但总之，我太喜欢它们了，在纽约找不到做得一样的地方。
So I finally was like, all right, I'm just going to reach out to the airline on Twitter and be like, hey, can you give me your freaking noodle recipe? And so I did that. And, um, uh, I, I, this was, so I think I first tried calling them, um, and, uh, their customer service was like, yeah, we can't help you. And then I tried, uh, contenting them on twitter and then i tried emailing a few people and no luck but then i eventually i finally i found the recipe online um from the from the chef so now i have the cathay pacific um dan dan mian lounge noodles recipe and i do intend on making them soon. Yeah. All right. Well, I hope the listener enjoyed that.
所以我最后觉得：“好吧，我直接在 Twitter 上联系航空公司，问问：‘嘿，能把你们那该死的手擀面/面条食谱给我吗？’”所以我这么做了。然后，嗯，呃，我——我想我最开始是尝试打电话给他们，嗯，呃，他们的客服说：“是的，我们帮不了你。”然后我试着，嗯，在 Twitter 上联系他们，然后我尝试给几个人发邮件，但都没用。但后来我终于，我终于在网上找到了食谱，嗯，是那位主厨的。所以现在我有国泰航空，嗯，担担面贵宾室面条的食谱了，我确实打算最近自己做。好吧。嗯，希望听众会喜欢这段。
I mean, I guess I shouldn't give you too hard of a time. I think I did mention on this podcast before that at one point I tried to reach out to Cinnabon to get them to sponsor me for my races. Yeah. Although I'm not a big Cinnabon fan anymore, to be honest. I wonder if I could get a local restaurant or not restaurant. Like there's two donut places that I really like in Toronto. One of them is called Harry and Heels, which is actually, it's interesting what they've done. It's a pizza restaurant.
我是说，我想我不该给你太大的压力。我想我以前在这个播客里提到过，我曾一度试图联系 Cinnabon（美式肉桂卷），让他们赞助我的比赛。对。虽然说实话，我现在已经不是 Cinnabon 的超级粉丝了。我在想，我能不能找一家当地的餐馆——或者说不是餐馆。比如我在多伦多非常喜欢的两家甜甜圈店。其中一家叫 Harry and Heels，实际上，他们做的事很有趣。它是一家披萨店。
But because of online delivery services, they've just. It's a pizza restaurant, but because of online like delivery services, they've just created a secondary business that they call Harry and heels that only sells the donuts that they sell at their pizza store. So it's like, Oh, we're at a donut shop. And the first time I went there, I was like, this is a pizza shop. It's not a donut shop, but like they just, they market it as two different things because if it's just a pizza restaurant and people are looking for donuts, they're never going to end up on the sort of pizza store. And there's another one called Unholy Donuts, which I only I went into the store the first time a couple of weeks ago. And I was so confused because I don't like filled donuts.
但因为在线外卖服务，他们只是——它是一家披萨店，但因为在线外卖服务，他们只是创建了一个副业，他们把这个副业叫做 Harry and heels，只卖他们在披萨店里卖的甜甜圈。所以感觉就像是：“哦，我们来到了一家甜甜圈店。”我第一次去的时候还在想：“这是一家披萨店，不是甜甜圈店。”但他们只是把它作为两件事来营销，因为如果它只是一家披萨店，而人们在寻找甜甜圈，他们永远不会最终光顾这家披萨店。还有另一家叫 Unholy Donuts（不神圣甜甜圈），我几周前第一次走进那家店。我当时非常困惑，因为我不喜欢带夹心的甜甜圈。
I don't like filled donuts because it's just too many textures. It's upsetting. And all of their donuts looked like they were filled and i was like oh how do you feel about eclairs oh i absolutely hate them name something where it's like uh pastry or like the gusher is the worst i was gonna bring you offender it was for cpp north but i guess i'm gonna bring you something else no if it's got... You know that Ramona and I met at McClure Bakery. I did not know that. I mean, you met on a dating app.
我不喜欢带夹心的甜甜圈，因为口感太丰富了。这让人心烦。而且他们所有的甜甜圈看起来都是带夹心的，我就在想：“哦，你对闪电泡芙（eclairs）怎么看？”哦，我绝对讨厌它们。说出一个类似的东西，比如糕点或者——夹心糖（gusher）是最糟糕的。我本来要带给你一个得罪人的东西，是为了 C++ North 大会的，但我想我要带别的给你。不，如果它有……你知道 Ramona 和我在麦克卢尔面包店（McClure Bakery）相遇的吗？我不知道。我的意思是，你们是在约会软件上认识的。
Yeah, that is true. Your first date was probably... Like, let's be clear. Let's be clear. But yeah, this Unholy Donuts place, I went in and all of them looked filled. And then I asked the lady behind the counter, oh, you guys don't have any unfilled donuts? And she's like, yeah, the sprinkle, the cinnamon, the Homer, and like one other one are not filled. And I was like, huh? And so I ordered a sprinkle one.
对，那是真的。你们的第一次约会可能……咱们把话说清楚。咱们把话说清楚。不过是的，这个 Unholy Donuts 店，我走进去，所有的看起来都带夹心。然后我问柜台后面的女士：“哦，你们这里没有不带夹心的甜甜圈吗？”她说：“有的，撒糖珠的（sprinkle）、肉桂的、霍默（Homer）款的，还有另外一款是不带夹心的。”我当时想：“啊？”所以我点了一个撒糖珠的。
Sure enough, the reason they're called unholy donuts is because they don't have holes in them. Oh. Which I didn't put together. That's pretty clever. But you think we can get one of them to sponsor us? I mean, not this podcast. I mean, maybe I could get the new bodega on my block to sponsor us because I'm pretty sure
果然，它们之所以被称为“不神圣的甜甜圈”，是因为里面没有洞。哦。我之前没把这两者联系起来。这挺聪明的。但你觉得我们能让其中一个赞助我们吗？我是说，不是这个播客。我是说，也许我可以让街区里的新杂货店（bodega）赞助我们，因为我很确定
that we are the sole reason that their smoothie operation stays in business. They've got a problem now that Ramona's uh up in albany uh a good chunk of the time yeah i don't i feel like a local business wouldn't like i was thinking more to get sponsored for for racing like if you're racing in a singlet that says you know yeah yeah run for the unholy donuts or whatever um for this podcast not as much because like what percentage of our listeners are in toronto no no your your thing makes more sense than my thing i'll admit that yeah although it would be interesting to find like it it'd have to be like that's why i
我们是他们奶昔生意能维持下去的唯一原因。他们现在面临一个问题，就是 Ramona，嗯，大部分时间都在奥尔巴尼呆着。对，我感觉当地企业不会喜欢——我当时想的是拉赞助是为了跑步，比如如果你穿着一件印有“为不神圣的甜甜圈而跑”之类字样的单衣去跑步，嗯，嗯……为了这个播客就不太行了，因为毕竟我们的听众里有多少人在多伦多？不，不，你的想法比我的更有道理，我承认这一点。是的，虽然找到一个——那必须是——这就是为什么我
thought you know lululemon it's like global right or at least it's both america lemon call us call us yeah you know we we had a whole episode dedicated basically to this. Or like there's so many companies like American Airlines. You could sponsor us. I stopped spending money on bubbly though. I only have one of those cartridges with the little squirt squirt soda buzzes. What do they call them? Whatever.
觉得，你知道，露露乐蒙（Lululemon），它是全球性的，对吧？或者至少是全美性的。Lululemon，给我们打电话，给我们打电话。是的，你知道的，我们有一整期节目基本上都是专门讲这个的。或者还有那么多公司，比如美国航空。你可以赞助我们。不过我不再花钱买气泡水了。我只有一个那种带喷射苏打气泡的小气瓶。它们叫什么来着？随便吧。
Soda streams. And I got the flavors. But honestly, like you can add so much carbonation like you just keep going and uh it's it's so overwhelming that you don't need flavors the flavors are meaningless when you've got basically just like an explosion of carbon dioxide in your mouth anyways uh okay this conversation's gone off the rails yeah it's even for us it's gone off the rails i have determined though in the back of my head that um this max gap count problem is not going to follow the same pattern as uh cadanes and maximum consecutive ones yeah i don't
苏打水机（Soda streams）。我有各种口味。但老实说，你可以加入那么多的碳酸气，你只要一直加，嗯，这太浓烈了，你根本不需要什么口味。当你嘴里基本上只有二氧化碳的爆炸时，口味根本毫无意义。不管怎样，好吧，这段对话已经彻底跑偏了。对，即使对我们来说也彻底跑偏了。不过我在脑子里已经决定了，嗯，这个最大间隙计数问题将不会遵循与卡丹算法和最大连续 1 相同的模式。对，我不
think so because it's just a reduction not an inclusive scan reduction yeah and it's actually probably won't even be that pretty because actually it might be well i'll i will solve it off off air and then maybe next episode and and see see this this connor i'm i'm dear listener i'm about to be very arrogant this connor is why i am a principal architect. Because you've been thinking about this for days. You hop onto a meeting with me and I'm like, oh yeah, just do it like that. And boom, the entire trajectory of your next week has been decided by me. And now I can go fuck off and go to sleep.
这么认为，因为这只是一个规约，而不是包含性的扫描规约。是的，而且它实际上可能甚至不会那么好看，因为其实它可能会——好吧，我会在线下解决它，然后在下一期节目中看看。看，看，康纳，我——亲爱的听众，我马上要变得非常傲慢了。康纳，这就是为什么我是首席架构师。因为你已经连续几天在考虑这个问题了。你一加入我和我的会议，我就说：“哦，对，就这样做。”然后轰的一声，你接下来一周的发展轨迹就这样被我决定了。现在我可以滚去睡觉了。
This is going to take all of 10 minutes to program in several different languages. Yes, but it required the two minutes of hard work that I did to lead you to the promised land. It is a certain amount sad that... Well, no, fake hubris aside, you know what the reality is? The reality is, and I think we all know this, that we often do our best work when speaking to
这在几种不同的语言里，花个 10 分钟就能写完。是的，但它需要我做的那两分钟的艰苦工作，才把你带到了应许之地。某种程度上确实挺可悲的……好吧，不，抛开虚假的自大不谈，你知道现实是什么吗？现实是——我想我们大家都知道——当我们与他人交谈
or collaborating with others. Because oftentimes, we lock in on, this is the way that we have to solve this problem. Or my old boss, Hartman, whenever we were debugging a performance problem, he would always be like, you got to watch for the red herrings, you know, you have to watch
或合作时，我们往往能做出最好的工作。因为通常情况下，我们会钻牛角尖，认为这就是解决这个问题的唯一途径。或者我的老老板哈特曼（Hartman），每当我们在调试性能问题时，他总是会说：“你得当心那些红鲱鱼（误导信息），你知道的，你得当心
for the things that seem like they're going to be the problem or the solution, but they're actually just a trap. And you probably just got off thinking about this one way and you were just stuck in that that course of thinking and just just you just needed somebody who was fresh to the problem to be like oh well you know my gut reaction is to do this um and and probably if my gut reaction had been wrong i probably would have spent you know two or three or four days thinking about how to solve it with the way that initially occurred to me. Um, and it would only be when somebody new looked at it, uh, that I'd spoken with that,
那些看起来像是问题或解决方案、但实际上只是个陷阱的东西。”你可能刚开始时只用一种方式去思考这个问题，然后你就陷入了那种思维定式中，你只需要一个对这个问题感到新鲜的人来说：“哦，好吧，你知道，我的直觉反应是这样做……”而且，如果我的直觉反应是错的，我可能大概会花两、三、四天的时间去思考如何用我最初想到的那种方式来解决它。只有当某个新的人看了它——一个我曾与之交谈过的人——
that I would be like, oh yeah, that's actually how to do it. Or maybe I'm really, or maybe really I'm just that much smarter than you. Could be either thing. Could be either thing. Could be. I mean, we'll never know, but, uh, it is, you know, the key insight is just recognizing that you don't need to, every time you hit a new max, you can still keep reducing. Because it, at least when I thought about it initially, I was like, well, at first I have to find the diffs. And then I need to find the maximum.
我才会想：“哦，对，实际上应该这样做。”或者也许我真的很——或者也许我真的比你聪明得多。都有可能。都有可能。也许吧。我的意思是，我们永远不会知道，但是，嗯，你知道的，关键的领悟仅仅在于认识到你不需要——每次你碰到一个新的最大值时，你仍然可以继续做规约。因为，至少当我最初想到它时，我觉得：“嗯，首先我必须找到差值。然后我需要找到最大值。
And then once I have the maximum, then I can do it. But it's not true. You can do those two things at the same time, which is like, at least for me, clearly was a non-obvious insight. This brings us to the end of the episode, starting from episode 115. If you don't have Twitter, there is going to be a link to a GitHub discussion on a per episode basis if you want to leave comments or questions, and we'll be monitoring that. Or you can also do it on Twitter,
然后一旦有了最大值，我就可以做了。”但事实并非如此。你可以同时做这两件事，这对我来说，显然是一个非显而易见的洞见。这就把我们带到了本期节目的尾声，从第 115 期开始。如果你没有 Twitter，在每一期节目的基础上都会有一个链接指向 GitHub 讨论区，如果你想留下评论或问题，我们会去监控那个地方。或者你也可以在 Twitter 上留言，
which is typically where we hang out. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoy and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那通常是我们出没的地方。谢谢收听。希望你们喜欢，祝大家有个美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。